[Music]
in bad suggestion news over there one
time and I started throwing up in there
that's probably cuz we leave it open and
it's here for like it was delicious
stuff no but is it is it a thing if you
eat too much mango you throw up I know
you get diarrhea cuz all the fiber I
know that if you need to went to bingo
you can actually get sick like you catch
a cold sick because like I ate five or
six and one floor I don't know and the
next day like literally I was coughing I
was like what the [ __ ] but colds are
caused by virus or yeah I came back from
the hospital all sick babies and they
ate five mingles and I got sick
something about like Oh too much warm
food in your system and I'm like yeah
that's what they say but like jackfruit
or Patrick you to put rocks on your face
and then [ __ ] animal later maybe find
them components to make a bomb or
appearing in Amazon's frequently bought
together tool what's nice to know holy
[ __ ] people are buying bomb parts it's
like it's random things to the guy that
I went on got my punches what the hell
is this costume cracker butt cheek butt
cheek I thought you're talking about
your butthole me that's the first time I
ever heard him call somebody else
disgusting have you seen in Washington
Hawaii oh yeah this will probably as a
porn star nestled edition is bleached
why it has no right to call other people
disgust yeah
except for my butthole your butthole
does shits clean no uh like bomb
components member when I went to the
desert to shoot guns and I split my head
oh yeah the one guy whose family owns
that property that we were shooting guns
in he was like this military whatever
and he makes explosives that we were
shooting and just put it in like a
ziploc bag it's like it's fertilizer and
some sort of crystal and salt and colors
and bloody ball whatever and he can
change the clothes oh whoops oh yeah oh
do you know how to make that to the
phobias surprise surprise there's 101
class yeah if I lived in a desert and I
had a lot of land I think I'd do the
same [ __ ] yeah I'd be blowing [ __ ] up
yeah like it's yet to bring it
separately and then mix it together and
then he can change it's like Oh what
color explosion do you want I can make
it pink I can't make it work I can make
it Sparkle you on it so it's just like
regular household stuff it's gonna have
glitter oh he learned it from the
Unabomber that's what it was that's the
manual they were like hi friends oh he's
like my friend Ted Kaczynski or Ted
Kaczynski yeah you know he was a child
genius Ted Kaczynski yeah like he was
one of those childlike he was on TV and
all that stuff and then he was super
intelligent but the Unabomber was a
child like genius star he was supposed
to be like Oh somebody great and then he
became a recluse and he started bombing
[ __ ] oh wait he moved up to the forest
yeah do you think he's like so smart
that he can just take anymore and he
just saw himself above other people yeah
I was watching this thing about like god
complex people that are too intelligent
and then they end up not being able to
have friends and [ __ ] like that yeah
it's a lonely world for them I must be
really stupid that is a statistic though
they said like people that aren't like
super high IQ they tend to have more
friends
that points on that you have a high EQ
this right if they're there they're not
a lower IQ and low in poverty too
because they tend to depend on other
people they work as community so they
have more friends hmm I just don't care
so if you're high IQ and poverty what's
that normal I know how to make money but
[Laughter]
we Niels ruin everything
so Britain's Channel 4 News found that
Amazon's algorithm to suggest other
products that people also buy they've
been suggesting a lot of products that
can make explosives together and so
recently amazon.com said that they would
be reviewing their site after that
investigation to make sure that that
doesn't happen anymore but it's pretty
crazy that a lot of these ingredients
have been just meshed together with
frequently bought items are just kind of
scary especially recently since they had
that bucket bomb in the train station so
it's pretty great ok that's crazy that
people are buying bomb parts on Amazon
the shipping is too good this one I
don't have to take off my son I don't
have to go outside to buy things that
come straight to my door Isis
commercials like a priest and then yeah
or something or they get like knee pads
cuz they pray a lot I think so but it's
like two religions coming together and
one helps the other because he knows it
he's a kneeling for too long and the
other one gets a package from that
priest too and sees it oh it's also
kneel kneepads because they care about
each other it was something about like
religions can get along is really it's a
really cute our monk that's calling
bottom of dish
head with no pads [ __ ] man that's all I
ever get you guys like the frequently
bought together hell yeah
it helps me yeah something like forgot
the batteries thank you genius or like
when they had those bundles but like the
item you're looking at whatever whatever
equals like the amount and then just get
up do you guys feel badly to break the
bundle like for example you buy one
thing right and I'll tell you you also
got to get these three other things and
you look at a miller well technically I
only need these two other things but
then you're like but then it is grouped
together nice leaves on my [ __ ] I
just buy it and they're not half like
two other things I don't even need like
puppies I can't separate them they
belong together
this was a better deal to have the other
to be the same it's not because I'm just
buying it's like oh you want the surge
protector well you also should get a
batteries and also this oh my well we
need the surge protector I don't need a
battery but it is but enough to go
through nicely have you ever done this
well you're like Amazon surfing or some
[ __ ] little really late at night when
you're delirious yeah and then you buy
everything in the wake up in the morning
I'm like wow like who bought this [ __ ]
no it was like something I really I
didn't need no actually I tell myself
like okay I gotta save this for Tiffany
that hasn't been well rested I don't
actually purchase yeah cuz one time I
had a grappling hook and I had to get
the the cable for the grappling hook
suggested together I was like I thought
it came with it cuz I don't know I just
wanted it like try if it worked like you
know in the movies they do it and they
climb up so I wanted to get that and if
for some reason there was like a ninja
section ooh
so there was those claws they just call
me by this yeah I mean just also bought
this yeah it wasn't even like ninja but
then if you start looking for ninja [ __ ]
like all these like throwing stars
everything starts popping up so I
started getting all these ninja things
[ __ ] but I didn't buy it because I was
like I got enough Spears and swords I'm
gonna just calm down
yeah I'm not getting it I like other
websites I'll put like a ton of stuff
you can throw this stuff together it's
like all five hundred dollars and I see
shipping $10 and I'm like no I just
closed everything else I was gonna buy a
whole bunch of [ __ ] from a Honda Element
and then I realized I'm driving a Honda
Element
I was gonna get like Bream Oh like
[ __ ] rotors and like brake calipers
like for a hundred and sixty six
horsepower car like what the [ __ ] do I
need this for you know and then the cart
got a little bit ridiculous as I why do
I need this and I woke up in the morning
I was like well thank God you don't bite
it dumbass yeah I put it in my wish list
and then like a week later or something
I'll look at it [ __ ] you I want this
I'll get rid of it but that also makes
me think of like whenever I see like a
random like a [ __ ] a Toyota Tercel
and it's painted like matte blue with
the custom license plate and rims I'm
like why like the paint job is more
expensive than the car yeah like why
it's still a Tercel like why are you
doing this I'm trying to find that
balance between the plate what's so
stupid and what's not right now I like
that car too much it's just stupid one
of those helicopter things on your car I
just imagined it are you sure may come
they'll be dope like your car just has
propellers on the top and every time I
Drive it just that's gonna reduce my
speed on my car certain direction that
helps you yeah it lifts it up Paul David
odors gonna kick his ass for no reason
are you gonna give me a ticket no I know
it's a lot gonna shove you in KC and I
we recently bought Isaac a game
I think it's called rocket League we're
just pretty much it fun yeah so it's
like soccer but with cars and then you
can customize your cars and then one of
them was putting spinning wheels on it
and then I was like cool like I have
this imagine this was actually a real
thing and I was like I think they
actually had those people actually
bought those he's like who would buy
even
and you're like your uncle Han bought it
like a week ago for his [ __ ] Corolla
I didn't know anyone actually owned that
never saw your dad's a stroker and it's
like hubcap spinner yeah the ones like
if you flick it a go theme yeah yeah
what what what the manufacturer is Astro
I think with Chevy I'd be a snowman
every Korean flea market person had one
though he always had that turquoise
color one
yeah the dark turquoise could indeed
yeah turquoise is my arm still has
Russia's dope don't miss that thing it's
comfortable for other people I hope you
guys enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]